here's mitch keller on the mound for
pittsburgh era is third worst
in the sport minimum of 40 innings case
but the talent is there
mookie going over five yesterday you can
see on the five game trip
three for his last 22 the talent is
there
it's just about fastball command as the
2-0
is socked to center field reynolds
heading back gives it a look
forget about it third pitch of the game
mookie bets go long his sixth of the
year
it's one nothing dodgers wow you said it
you said it best right there scott
talking about mitch keller's fastball
command
that ball was right down the middle at
93 miles an hour
you can't miss the mookie bets right
down the middle he's going to make you
pay
and max muncie has the eye of a champion
he strikes out on some high heat from
keller cody's missed some time
this season around seven weeks looking
to get his timing back in the batter's
box but once his timing is back
he's as deadly a hitter as there is
as ballinger strikes out on three
pitches good fastball from keller to
beat him
aureus is 2-0 allowing two runs in 13
total innings
against pittsburgh overall a 1.38 eraser
he's been just electric against them
overall
veronica this is a guy right here that
you know that that's been
really got a chance to play stallings
you know they love him as a gold glover
behind the disc but he's really swung
the bat well for the pirates this year
lux will throw across athletic play to
complete the first
and hayes is stranded at third maria in
the dodgers up one nothing
after one max muncie who's been the
dodgers best overall hitter 13 bombs on
the season
got him to pop it up
tom has it and the inning is over
dodgers leave the bases loaded they do
have one from the bets homer
in the first as we head to the pirates
half of the second
there's bellinger who's missed the most
time so far point being not the
healthiest squad
that's opposite field hitting for the
pirates and it's eric gonzalez in
business
and the pirates are going to send home
evans
here he comes head first he's in there
we're tied at one
on the rbi double from eric gonzalez
and now it's kai tom you can see the non
fastballs
at just a buck 27. that's the curveball
and the changeup
2-2 is shipped to right bets
is gonna grab it made it look easy
but here comes gonzalez what a throw
from
it's on the money hitting me are you
kidding me
he does it so casually whirl and turtle
a rocket to home for the out
one of the best right fielders i've ever
seen now it's mckinn street juicy
opportunity with the bags full of
dodgers
case what was your arm strength at about
97
like 66 67
so that green line would have been in
the infield i
i took my kids recently to the kennywood
park out here which is a you know
amusement park in pittsburgh and i got
the three balls and
lined it up i'm like all right told my
son jake here you go i
and i did it 67 i i hit
past the green line for mckinstry and
that enables turner to score
easily the sac fly puts the dodgers back
in front it's
2-1 off the rbi marias can make some
loud contact at times the dodgers have
some pretty good hitting pitchers
2-2 sent to right and connects
bellinger comes home that'll score two
for the dodgers
[Applause]
make it seven rbis on the season for the
dodgers starter
it's four to one mookie betts
a home run on pitch number three of the
day his sixth of the season
he went around and stratton struck him
out
so he comes in picks up the one out he
needs and strands a couple base runner
but the dodgers attack with
three they knock out the starter mid
three
dodgers up 4-1 so now reynolds steps up
with haze on first
on the one two goes with the curve
reynolds hammers it
deep left beady gives it a look and it's
gone
brian reynolds for two number 10 on the
season
and the pirates make this a one run game
it's a big at-bat here for newman you
got two outs running on third base down
a run
big moment in the ball game lowest ops
in baseball so far this year
sends that one to right bets looking
and finding it and
he makes the catch to end the inning
mckinstry to a leaping gonzalez he plays
a nice first base
and that brings us to philip evans two
for two
singles in the second and the fourth
today
and we're in the sixth hitting he's
giving his manager a pretty good start
evans clocks it to left and there's
baity
a one two three sixth just like he
pulled off
in the fifth only five outs yesterday
from gonzalon so
maria says hey bullpen i got you today
mckinstry was off to a fast start
this season quickly making a name for
himself
he was leading all rookies with 14 rbis
on the 20th of april when he hit the
injured list
with a strained oblique a little quieter
since he returns
smacks that one past the infield and the
dodgers have a two run lead
bellinger comes in it's 5-3
chris taylor coming up with the bases
loaded and two outs in the seventh
see what he dials up on the o2 got him
serious breaking stuff from bednard to
compliment the big time fastball
look at him go in a major bind he comes
in prevents further damage but the
dodgers have a two run cushion
as we head to the bottom of the seventh
let's stretch
la was certainly the best fit for him
turner
sends a ball to center and it will fall
on a weird spin
and score a run mookie bets come on down
dodgers doubling up the pirates 6-3 in
the eighth in
rainey pnc park now bellinger
nobody out in the eighth
let's see if that's good enough for
hayes to grab
and he got it whoa wow
what a play he made that catch what a
oh my gosh yeah it's tart time
so three days in a row in pittsburgh
the game will step aside for a moment
thanks to mother nature